[Music]
seven miles off Estonia's west coast in
Eastern Europe lies the small island of
canoe a bucolic and serene place that
feels lost in time home to just 400
people it functions like one of the
world's few matriarchal societies this
is a place where women roll well mostly
everything
[Music]
my name is Morales I lived almost all my
life in this island our lifestyle is
different comparing the lifestyle in the
mainland many old traditions fill our
lives one such tradition is that canoes
men spend months away at sea fishing for
the island meanwhile canoes women are in
charge of leading the community and
preserving its way of life
men were always a long time away from
the island and such a historical reason
why women become a very strong very
independent kid no conscience
interesting because we have killer
additional costumes as I everyday
wearing she's making skirts because she
has five granddaughters we have ancient
folk songs still alive and dances they
have a lot of practical skills how to
live all over the year here yes life is
more difficult here to survive it's
treasure for two Islanders they all
described the island like it's like a
paradise it's the best place in the
world we had a male Rock camera era an
image in her go to her in the ring gear
I got rocked again nice and employee
said Kittleman amis in new a lot of
justice
Rika start up a leak Oh merciful the
clothes the music the dancing all of it
has been recognized by UNESCO on its
intangible cultural heritage list keen
on wedding songs and many traditions are
more than 2,000 years old so it's this
is a main thing why we are missus UNESCO
List
the same list acknowledges canoes women
as the custodians of their islands
heritage I concern everybody that our
unique culture can disappear it's very
valuable if those things still exist and
survived and the modern world it's
really miracle
[Music]
a two hour boat ride off the coast of
Colombia is an island the most densely
populated island on earth
[Music]
santa cruz del is latte consists of more
than 1,200 people living on land the
size of two soccer fields making it four
times as dense as manhattan on the
island is a school that runs up to the
tenth grade two shops and one restaurant
there is no steady supply of water and a
Seoul generator that only runs for five
hours per day there are no police but
there isn't much need for them as
everyone on the island knows each other
a hundred and fifty years ago the island
was primarily uninhabited and was
sometimes used by local fishermen as a
place to rest and take shelter during
storms gradually some fishermen came to
build their homes here these were the
grandparents and great-grandparents of
the current generation of residents
despite the close living quarters
inhabitants on the island say they
wouldn't give up their peaceful
existence for anything not even a little
more room the village of kamikatsu
is special not for its tea fields or
idyllic mountains or peaceful historic
homes
it's known for something it doesn't have
kamikatsu as a town produces almost no
trash kamikatsu has a population of
roughly 1500 people and in the 1990s was
doing nearly no recycling so de la moto
moto - on hot arid Atacama watch even
annuity Akaka by Imani Naha faster
burning all that garbage created carbon
dioxide emissions that became dangerous
and the nature around them was suffering
so a decision was made cami katsu had to
change this was the start of their path
toward zero waste and a new way of
living a minute it already so sing again
so it will know much sauce coconut hey
no get away a monocoque attachement I
know when you saying son many many
messes effectively what zero waste here
means is that there's no such thing as
throwing something in the trash
everything has to get recycled and in
the beginning it was difficult for
everyone like mr. Takuya Chaka Ichi
he's a shop owner in kamikatsu zero
estando a domotic hace cut away a play I
repeated of tiny larry maasdam
boomded soo-ji canto my at the particle
- you are - the viet and a tiny one
artistic and mrs. Tsuchiya katayama
she's a housewife
so should I know them to put a more
woman animal come guys and then we show
Nene mother
the idea time Jessica so there are no
God
yeah Congo moon bits of Aussie TV not
Tara the mother really must stop that
classification system she's talking
about is the key to coming car to
success and it is aggressive there are
forty five categories of recyclables
irony conspira-con spirit jean-jacques
say no Chuck you know mocha shake-a
found a list it goes on there's thirty
five more slowly what was originally
this huge burden
became a way of life in kamikatsu people
began looking at trash differently 100
daisuke matsuzaka 2013 you see it me
they will go me the damn ball
guilelessly
Kadamba wah but as i do stay composed
study soon it came as new phenomena
kurumada where Assad regime otaku
Faustina Cote inugami or subtitute
Inuvik una still eternal de Tabac was
she talking on company kayako Cyrano
Kazan no attack in Italian there never
thought you got scarce any medical
coding can lose I predict it at all
Scottish on Aparicio cholera see it's
important to recognize that kamikatsu is
a small town it is not like New York or
London the rules are not the same but
there is a constant and that's people
they can change I won't die why you
should fit in this catwalk so you can
look Elena camerin eyes and I got a fish
well cut our cake oh my much kumihimo
Taisho mashido got steep what you know
what he not say tomato
how could I not know cannot remove
Nakano much in each day they're always
the [ __ ] there did you see any up to
meet it no could about korekara
yeah pretty cool new video super dirty
shitty so that the Taliban in Chicago so
that cigar a Scottish Keo caramel and
Polly some awesome audio grab a Hilda
male hey Niko can teleport on Iook at
all took too much tongue guy tomorrow
still to you like an emerald IG
shreekant we get windy spangled with Abu
Naga Chicka Boom Boom of escape
[Music]
[Music]
there's somebody driving into town the
first time you wouldn't think there was
a lot here because 95% of it is hiding
underground people drive in and go where
is the place I don't understand Cuba PT
is from the aboriginal and Cooper pity
which means white man and a hole at the
moment upstairs
it is about 122 degrees Fahrenheit down
here we're sitting on about 71 72
degrees no air conditioning necessary
well right out in the middle of nowhere
it takes a day to drive here from
Adelaide outside is about a thousand
underground dwellings and at least 1500
people living on the ground we've got
five underground churches we've got
underground motels there's some amazing
underground homes here many bedrooms
underground workshop you name it
underground we've pretty well got it
I bought mine dug out as a fairly small
two-bedroom dug out and I've been
extending it over the years some other
side blasted out where I could get away
with it
the cops don't like is blasting intent
we don't do it anymore
back in the old days if somebody was
going to have a baby
we'd rock around there with a couple of
compressors on a weekend and some
jackhammers on the couple of cartons of
beer and by the Sunday night we dug out
of room cemented the floor and wired it
up and there's your new baby's room
honey
even though we're so far away
geographically from anywhere else but I
know why but we just loved the place to
piss
[Music]
we were the smallest town for a while
do we still wish we were I don't know to
be a population of one in the population
of two and you're both in the same
County in the same state I think that's
pretty wonderful
what is the population of mono i
population 1 me the population of gross
Nebraska is 1 2 1 2
we don't have enough people it's nothing
against the towns nothing against the
people running the businesses we simply
have run out of people out in this this
area all we have in town is the bank
vault that remains from the Gross State
Bank then we have a community hall and
then our house and a trailer house
across the street
we had a high school here there was
Church until pull maybe the mid sixties
we have the same paperwork and
everything to fill out that Omaha and
New York City and every other city has
we don't have an election for mayor I
just let him keep that job
[Music]
the young folks or any that go from here
to the city they can adjust pretty well
and make a good life there but you take
somebody that's born and raised in the
city and they usually just can't hack it
out in this area never gets lonely
living in a town of dude there's always
somebody passing through values are
different you don't have everything at
your fingertips so you just learn to
sitting and converse more I'm not here
because I have to be I can close up and
leave here anytime I want to go wherever
I wanted I'm here because I want to be
here
you
[Music]